you
all right welcome everybody it is
another day another press briefing
scheduled for the top of the hour now
there is more and more debate about
these press briefings should they be
covered or should they be ignored
because they are so filled with
disinformation toxic disgusting lies and
distortions from Donald Trump Donald
Trump yesterday not even mentioning the
caseload or the death toll it's now
about stocks bowing as he likes to call
it money the economy all of the stuff
the the fact that we have an explosive
death toll now is increasingly not even
a factor during these and as we now
learn that Donald Trump wants to to
quote Anthony foutch II let it rip
starting on April 12th I would expect
we're going to see even less discussion
of what is going on clinically and more
and more discussion about we got to open
up the economy and you guys all know
this stuff we are
I guess seven minutes from today's press
conference although they've been sort of
sort of running late and we are waiting
to hear or to see who it is that is even
up on the stage with Trump Trump
insisting that he and dr. fowey are just
doing fine together
but there is every indication that there
is a little bit of trouble in paradise
so to speak let me say thank you to
Chris di Pietro who is new member number
one today at join pakman.com we are now
really starting to see that tightening
of the belt that is understandable a lot
of membership cancellations and I get
why people are doing that everybody's
got to tighten the belt everywhere and I
get it were just some online show doing
you know doing analysis but for those
who can't afford a few bucks a month the
memberships that have been coming in
during the streams are really what's
helping to keep that imbalance so I
really appreciate it
really appreciate Chris grabbing that
membership let me remind you that
tonight at 8:00 p.m. Eastern
we've got everybody's at home David
Pakman show chess tournament there is a
trophy involved this is I'm the 2019
chess champion there was only one game
in 2019 I beat our producer Pat who
never plays and I am the champion
it's a very low you know it's not
nothing to brag about but we will have a
trophy for the winner of tonight's chess
tournament I'll be streaming live
starting at probably quarter of 8:00
Eastern tonight anybody can play
everybody's invited we'll be playing on
Leach s org let's look at some of the
super chats coming in here
Matt Chavez says why are the doctors
defending Trump what's in it for them
well whether they're defending or simply
not aggressively opposing is a question
and I think it's clear they don't feel
that they are in a position to really be
able to speak freely about what they
about what they believe is going on
ian's sends a dollar super chat adams
says David tell Madison she's cute and
then Madison says hi Adam - Adam so
apparently conversations happening
between people via super chat which is
fine I guess if you need to pay me to
talk to each other I wonder what so
what's going on there that's something
that something to look into
let me say thanks to Thomas Saverin for
subscribing on Twitch Agoda
has subscribed with twitch Prime glurg a
bull gash manic has subscribed with
Prime and a e7c has also subscribed with
prime also Lisa lemur has subscribed
with prime I'm gonna play something for
you guys because we we really need some
levity okay we really really do here is
a compilation of boomer David Pakman
that a viewer made and I think you guys
are going to enjoy his we really need
something like this right now let's take
a look at this together I think you're
gonna love it
hold on a second let me pause it and let
me turn up the volume and we're gonna
take it from the top okay check that I
actually have made an account and I am
going to do a premiere stream
you
Oh David Kenneth destiny bunnell ii and
you've got to wait for the coda as well
there's a key coda here I tweeted this
for people who want it poopoo Pike or
browned out in this debate
Pepe laughs I don't is that French I
don't know what language that person
speaking so they actually have made an
array I'm going to an incredible
incredible this is up there with this is
some of the foremost cinema of our time
I would say so that was very very
compelling stuff and appreciate
everybody who participated in that in
one way shape or form as we wait for
today's press briefing okay other super
chats coming in let's see here
joke rock'n berg says when's our trump
bucks coming soon maybe we you know we
don't know ryan nawicki says I've heard
kovat will hurt Bernie's chances at the
primary and Trump's overall response to
the pandemic will affect his general
chances what are your thoughts I think
in the net kovat helps Trump get
reelected I hope I'm wrong I hope I'm
wrong but that's my best assessment Ian
says my girlfriend has a huge crush on
you
Ian that sounds like a problem that's
something you're gonna have to deal with
Alex Jones says really you're not going
to read my super chat Alex I told you
I'm not going to read any super chats
that are just trying to get me to insult
you you know other youtubers and stuff
like that Martha Gaytan is a new YouTube
member Trish vas is a YouTube member
DeAndre Clark says stop doing these
there's better uses of your time you
know what there really isn't because I'm
home all day and that this is it this is
this is what it is so we're gonna keep
doing this and remember our memberships
are really starting to go down because
of the financial crisis that we're in so
doing these we need to do these just to
recover members that's the crazy thing
and on that note remember you can sign
up at join pakman.com we have a goal
today of 25 members a beautiful
beautiful number Eric Rothschild says
David perhaps your hair needs to point
towards the sky in order to provide us
with hope not we're not doing that right
now we're not doing that right now maybe
if we get to 25
members something like that will happen
newah matt says the hill reports Trump's
highest approval in two years what is
happening America yeah so here's what's
interesting if you look at there's a new
poll about who do you trust
on coronavirus and anthony foul she is
the most trusted followed by andrew
Cuomo followed by dr. Burks and Trump is
almost at the bottom like people
realized they can't trust what Trump
says on coronavirus and yet his approval
rating is up and his general approval
for handling of the virus is pretty high
it's like fifty five fifty eight percent
something like that how could both be
true here's what I think is going on in
a general way during times of crises
people are more likely to say they
approve of the job the president's doing
even if the president doing nothing or
an acutely bad job that's number one the
rally around the president effect in
addition to that a lot of the country
does not have very many known cases of
the virus now if they were testing they
may have many more so geographically
there's probably a lot of parts of the
country where people can say I am I I
sort of I I think he is doing an okay
job because in my area things are fine
they may not be and they may not be for
much longer that's my sense of why those
numbers are looking that way map let me
say thank you to chaos binge who has
subscribed with twitch prime very much
appreciate that chaos binge subscribing
with twitch prime Martha Gaytan says has
stock in the company that makes
hydrochloric win gone up well I believe
there's a few companies that make it
Bayer is one and it's been pretty even
and there are I think there are some
other companies that also make make that
medication let's see what we've got live
streams starting soon scheduled for the
top of the hour we're now a couple
minutes past that time waiting to fade
says if the twelve hundred dollars is
based on tax returns how will it help
the homeless population arguably the
ones most at risk of getting and
transmitting the virus excellent
question
to which we don't yet have an answer Ben
Taylor's has loved the video you were
adorable
Ian says I gave my girlfriend a hall
pass
you Wow that is breaking breaking news
very aggressive cool m-43 says
number-one fan thank you McNally says
our people on social security going to
get cash from stimulus checks as far as
I know the answer to that is yes
Randy Johnston grabs a YouTube
membership pair Tirin says being late is
a power display that I've seen globally
for 20 years in my former possession
profession when the high rancor is very
insecure yeah Trump wants to sort of
hold people hostage in some way I think
that may be a factor I think it is a he
perceives it as a power move to be late
everyday let me say thank you to helen
Frater Helen Frater is new member number
two today at join pakman.com and Matthew
Stewart is new member number three today
at join pakman.com also Tyler Fraga is
new member number four at join
pakman.com reminder if you guys don't
have plans tonight in three hours
consider yourself invited to play in the
david pakman show twenty twenty chess
tournament okay make an account on Leach
s org allied chess org the tournament
starts at eight I will stream again
tonight I'll stream my game so if you
just want to watch me get crushed in
chess in the tournament you can watch me
stream but you can also play in the
tournament all skill levels welcome it's
free it costs nothing okay it's just a
free thing that we are doing quick
update of the coronavirus numbers the
official number now is four hundred and
sixty three thousand cases twenty
thousand almost twenty-one thousand
deaths these the the charts are in there
is just a straight up the death chart is
almost starting to go off of its own
axes because it's increasing so quickly
Donald Trump is talking about let it rip
starting April 12th and that's an
aggressively bad idea when you now look
at the number of active known cases we
are number one when you look at the
number of new cases today we are number
one
when you look at the number of total
cases we are still in number three but
remember we're barely testing and we are
likely going to jump into the number one
position
you know Trump talks about getting good
marks and good numbers these numbers are
quickly going in the wrong direction
very very wrong if we look
state-by-state you will see that our 910
deaths are coming about a third all in
New York State about a sixth from
Washington and then you've got other
places Louisiana is very quickly
becoming a big hot spot much higher
death rate in Louisiana than in
California you will notice Louisiana I
don't know that much about Louisiana's
health care system I know Mississippi's
right nearby is bonkers atrocious I mean
just disastrous disastrous health system
in Mississippi and meanwhile the
governor of Mississippi is like yeah let
it let it rip starting April 12th he
loves it
but it's getting very very bad it's
getting very bad and so far no
indication that we've turned the corner
in any way more cases every single day
so far more deaths every single day with
deaths almost doubling from yes
yesterday from the day before 2:25
yesterday and then of course today we
are already at 1:30 and that hasn't
moved for hours so you know it doesn't
seem like it's being updated in real
time so the numbers are getting very
very ugly now meanwhile Italy looked
like it was starting to turn things
around and indeed so a little bit of an
uptick in new cases yesterday but still
well below the peak and we'll see what
happens today
where is Italy today actually Italy
52:10 okay so another not a good day in
Italy but again they're not back up to
this crazy number of 6500 and we're
getting close to midnight they're in
Italy as far as deaths in Italy again
going back up yesterday deaths and cases
kind of tracking actually pretty closely
which makes sense because it all
reflects the situation at some previous
point when you think of the delay from
symptom to going to the hospital to
positive tests to death
it makes sense that that those would
move roughly in tandem so this is the
you know I don't know how you say we're
good we're about ready to let it rip
unless you are going to Oh Italy's
reporting only once per day now okay
that's important to know I don't see how
this is the time to let it rip
as we've heard said many many times
before I'm gonna refresh this cuz it
weirdly says live in 12 minutes and it
said that for a while oh here we go okay
we're live in the room now good and
folks are starting to file in let's see
here let me say thank you to Sammy's
tech for the twitch Prime subscription
on twitch obviously twitch prime is on
twitch let me say thank you to Rene Rose
Rene Rose is new member number five
today at join pakman.com Thank You Rene
very much appreciate your support there
and if you're just joining us scheduled
for five you know it's 508 sometime I'm
guessing in the next 10 or 15 minutes
things will get going although still the
briefing room looking very very bare as
of right now okay other super chats
coming in here let's see jared cam
barrows says before we go on please
share like and sub people complain about
joe biden not doing anything about the
virus remember he is not an elected
official yet the best thing in there is
yes if you're watching on youtube
remember to hit the like button and hit
the subscribe button both very important
it helps me personally when you hit like
and when you hit subscribe
that being said Biden's little press
conferences have not been going very
well so far frontier brain Robbie says
3d printing masks for family to use with
merv 13 filters 50% protection is better
than nothing do you want one David sure
send me would I would be glad to see
that to see one of them and the Mass
General president has actually said
please start 3d printing masks it's time
to do it user to 41000 sends a super
chat mini Murtagh subscribe
on YouTube Ian says are you for
legalized prostitution you know I think
I am the arguments in favor are better
to me than the arguments against
protection of sex workers seems like a
really important thing I've heard
elements not of medical but just
elements of compelling arguments on both
sides but I lean towards yes I lean
towards yes
Jennifer Lockwood has grabbed a YouTube
membership so is Robert Archer jonathan
is el Kowski says using my Trump bucks
to bet on the economy tanking in other
words you're going to take your $1,200
and then use it too short to buy short
puts maybe I don't know hype Kanak says
hey David I love what you're doing here
I've been watching for a long time and
greatly appreciate your efforts to keep
the public informed with facts and data
I'm glad to see you are working hard to
do what you do thank you I appreciate
your support
very generous a $40 super chat user says
Switzerland is currently the number one
per 10 thousands infected but Trump is
working hard to take our place America
first greetings from Switzerland yeah
the Switzerland has many many cases
let's go back and look at those numbers
Switzerland with 10,000 cases and cases
per million population well you've got
to get away from San Marino Vatican City
Faroe Islands Endora
Iceland Luxembourg and Liechtenstein but
once you get past that all tiny teeny
tiny places Switzerland is the the I
don't want to call it a real country
that's that would be so offensive to
people from San Marino and the Faroe
Islands but sometimes with very small
numbers per capita data can get very
very distorted so yes Switzerland with a
very high rate and looks like about a
1.5 percent death rate so far when you
look at death rates San Marino also very
high but again the numbers are so small
I don't know how much we learned from it
Italy is really the major country with
the highest death rate followed by Spain
Iran Netherlands and of course remember
this all depends on case data which may
main may not be super accurate the
bigger that denominator is the lower the
death rate becomes in practice not in
practice in in reality let me say thank
you to uh oh no nobody I thought I had
somebody to thank there but I actually
did not okay there we go let's see
Krusty sponge sends a super chat Alex
Jones says why isn't fascism left-wing
does left-wing mean more government and
the right-wing means less government
destiny is a friend of Pakman I've
addressed these these things so many
times that we're not going to do them
right now Alex but yeah check out my
videos about that Amanda Hagen kiss has
grabbed a youtube membership vegan cat
croissant says sending you all love from
London UK stay safe likewise likewise
stay safe in the UK as well Rasmus
haymaker says mind blown by martin
magnus carlsen also him or Kasparov
I don't know both you know Garry
Kasparov and Magnus I think Garry
Kasparov is probably a better chess
teacher than Magnus Carlsen but I think
at least as far as rating is concerned
Magnus a better player at his peak than
Kasparov at his peak I think somebody
can correct me if I'm wrong we'll find
out tonight during the chess tournament
that's for sure Chris Simpson says with
the house being out of session what do
you think the probability of the
stimulus bill passing by unanimous
consent don't know the answer to that
but it's got to get passed everywhere
soon people need money I now know a
number of people that have been laid off
and we've just we have to get the money
to people soon and we'll see if Donald
Trump has anything to say about it today
Donna Williams says thanks David for
doing the live videos Trump's cult
members still comparing this to the flu
very dangerous that's it's so dangerous
when they do that we are in the middle
of a hype train a level 2 hype train on
twitch we've got about 50 seconds left
to get to level 3 it's gonna be very
close
is trying to get us there it's me John B
has done his part
grungy dan did his part how sixty five
MD and [ __ ] cherina
have done all of their parts but we may
or may not get there we're down to just
30 seconds there and it could get very
ugly I want to warn everybody just so
everybody knows it sometimes people get
irate when a hype train fails at only
level level - Oh people are jumping on
the bandwagon detective John Kimble and
pakka's are mal mad sir has jumped right
in and it's coming down to the last nine
eight seven turkey bacon and cheese in
there with the wind gifting five
subscriptions and getting us getting us
to level three very very excitedly as
well as psycho coaster what's
everybody's best assessment about why
the press conferences start late every
day we heard from parity ran from from
from Europe that from Sweden that it's a
power move that Trump is exhibiting
power by making people wait for him
other ideas about what it is that drives
these press conferences to start late
Trump's watching Fox News he
spray-tanning it's Obama's fault Trump's
in the bathroom he's waiting for the
uppers to hit interesting most people
seem to think it's some combination of
laziness waiting for more ratings as
Trump likes to say and triggering people
yeah all of those could certainly be
factors all possibilities let me say
thank you to Michael Gartner Michael is
new member number six today at joined
pakman.com Michael thank you thank you
thank you
and Michael actually not even using the
coupon code the coupon code 2020 now
does save you 66% Michael sent a middle
finger to the coupon code and didn't use
it and Michael's paying full price
really appreciate your support very much
so Louis Nodin says here in the UK a
girl died aged 21 no previous health
conditions yeah you know whenever we
hear that this is essentially not
dangerous for young folk
once you get hundreds of thousands or
millions of cases you will have young
folks who are healthy with no
comorbidities who will die and we won't
ever know exactly why and this is why
it's particularly irresponsible for
young people to just be you know going
out going all around and be behaving
extraordinarily irresponsibly we have
succeeded with the level 5 hype train on
Twitch congratulations everybody we did
it we did it
incredible oh no that's level 4 sorry
that wasn't level 5 I'm completely wrong
about that we are now on level 5 gianni
X 3 says David you have ruined the word
elements for me Trump has ruined the
word elements with this whole elements
of medical thing Krusty sponge sends a
super chat Christopher hellström says
keep up the good work David really enjoy
your show Thank You Christopher I
appreciate your support
unknown prodigy oops hold on a second
where is unknown prodigy there is
unknown prodigy says do you know chess
openings how good are you I'm rated 1300
in slower chests and successively lower
and lower in faster chests I've
basically as white been playing upon
Jionni for several months and trying to
get better with that Mike Valverde says
should Democrats focus on winning the
Senate Biden looks awful well there's no
reason to forgo trying to knock Trump
out just because you're trying to win
the Senate you can do you can certainly
do two things at once
and Democrats should be doing it hella
cool guys says do you smoke weed I do
not I don't smoke anything I believe
that breathing in smoke of any kind
whether it's banana leaf or legal pad
paper that you're burning or whatever
it's bad for you and in fact we're
seeing a lot of that now with with
coronavirus a respiratory respiratory
virus respiratory illness not good not
good folks not good at all if you're
just joining us on YouTube we are indeed
at 18 minutes late right now it looks
like somebody just opened the door and
maybe yelled something out we could be
getting closer if you're just joining
though on youtube remember to hit like
and sub
scribe both very useful elements of
YouTube for us that I appreciate Amon
min-ji's says David do you think any
federal courts will go after members of
the Trump administration for their
criminal criminally negligent handling
of the whole pandemic know if you're if
that's what you're waiting for you are
going to be very disappointed that's not
going to happen thanks to Brandon
diamond for grabbing the SOI boy level
membership the three-point shot says hey
David you should take the political
compass test online takes five to ten
minutes I've done it five times during
the course of the David Pakman show
every time I do it every year year and a
half I get more and more left isn't that
incredible every you can find my videos
where I've widely uh widely widely done
that I want to say thank you to an
anonymous gift er for gifting twenty
subscriptions on Twitch and along with
Beaufort one Dre thirty three molten and
Crocky lemons as well as say CONMEBOL's
I get it I get it a on and Robin the son
Zack / Kowski grungy Dan everybody has
gotten us to a complete success on
hypetrain level five we are completely
off the charts four hundred percent I
think we've never done it before
incredible incredible stunning and
people what people over on Twitch seem
to be absolutely losing their minds
about about what's going on here okay
other super chats coming in as we wait
for Donald Trump
James Aleppo says I'm 21 about to
graduate from college living with
parents don't anticipate being able to
find a job for a while will I qualify
for a stimulus check my understanding is
you will how you sort of like sign up
for it and trigger the payment we don't
yet know we don't know what that
mechanism is going to be quite yet
incredibly it looks like we've maxed out
the hype train I don't know if it goes
any higher than 400 percent I think it
might just top out at four hundred
percent guess we don't know interesting
sensible talks us thanks for keeping me
sane during crazy times oh speaking of
which so there's now a debate starting
about
should the legacy corporate media
networks broadcast these press
conferences and the two views that are
pulling against each other seemed to be
this is the president saying stuff so
it's important to know what the
president is saying even if he's not
telling the truth about almost anything
the other side of it is it's
disinformation and it should be ignored
my take on this is broadcast networks
should run the press conferences but be
ready to fact-check in real time period
right i'm not patting myself on the back
for it but that's what I try to do when
Trump says GM is producing masks okay I
immediately say no GM said they are
gathering a parts list so that they can
start to acquire parts - at some point
in the future
build that not masks ventilators I'm
sorry if corporate media was prepared to
do that and willing to do it because
they would take heat they would take
heat if they fact I mean fact-checking
this is it's crazy because it's filled
with lies then it would be far more
responsible for them to run it it seems
that corporate media is debating between
running these press conferences with no
fact-checking whatsoever or not running
them at all I think what we should be
doing is running them and fact-checking
and even better the the press
conferences should really be led by the
doctors I don't even think Trump should
be at these press conferences he just
lies I want to hear from kouchi I want
to hear from Burks but more importantly
I want to hear from them without Trump
hovering over them and clearly
influencing what they're willing to say
because that's not good for anybody let
me say thank you to Byron sour sour
Byron's sour is new member number seven
today at join pakman.com ruddy Nazario
is new member number eight today at join
pakman.com very much appreciate that I
also want to say thank you too
there is one other person here who
signed up Hamilton to see Mae Hamilton
to see Mae is new member number nine
today at join pakman.com thanks for your
support very very much appreciate it
okay
Alex Jones says
just read manufacturing consent what are
your thoughts on it I think the
propaganda model is a very interesting
model to understand as laid out by Noam
Chomsky and the other guy I forget the
other author's name in manufacturing
consent I think
Chomsky's characterizations of some of
the historical elements of that book are
very much one-sided and not unanimously
accepted historical perspectives let me
put it that way but the propaganda model
is laid out in manufacturing consent
consent can be pretty useful for
understanding a lot of what we see in in
media today Brian Tyler says Trump seems
to be Arctic artificially keeping test
kits out of hands to keep the numbers
low that may be happening yeah I mean it
certainly he seems to think lower case
numbers are better for him Ross Pagar
Ian says going to tell my landlord rent
is coming in May
lol you and a lot of people Ross you and
a lot of people Jarrod Simard says have
you commented on dr. Jordan Peterson's
rehabilitation from clonazepam and
emergency trip to Russia no I mean
listen I've found Jordan Peterson to be
widely charlatans esque
for a very long time I don't you know
his personal medical issues like that
whole diet thing of eating only meat
that seems pretty wacky and I've
commented on that a little bit but he
got addicted to a drug his wife I
believe had you know it's gossip it's
guy just don't care I mean I think the
world is better served by Jordan
Peterson not being very present in
general that being said having to be in
a medically induced coma to get off of
klonopin in Russia is not you know that
what I would wish for anybody to be
caused to be sidelined by and and beyond
that it's basically gossip at this point
somebody's asking whether I've seen
Trump's latest tweet let's look at it
right now
the lamestream media is the dominant
force in trying to get me to keep our
country closed as long as possible in
the hope that it will be detrimental to
my election success oh boy the real
people want to get back to work ASAP we
will be stronger than ever
for I'm gonna retweet that with we are
screwed we are screwed folks you guys
want to retweet that this is a great
opportunity but that is very very ugly
stuff yeah that's that's very bad I'm
Deepak Minh on Twitter by the way
PA que ma n of course that that's
horrifying because again this went from
being Trump says this is a medical event
not a financial event really it's both
it very quickly went from this is a this
is a medical and financial event to this
is just a political event as far as
Donald Trump is concerned and that's
that's horrifying
that's horrifying because a lot of
people are gonna die like this is how
people die that's it this is how people
die okay the forces dead says I'm in
Louisiana my mom has been tested for
coronavirus they said it's two weeks to
get results I don't know if that's
normal but I assume we're super backed
up yeah I have friends here in
Massachusetts who have been told the
same thing and it's unfortunate I the
latest I read is it'll be three weeks
until we're in a 24 hour testing cycle
where the numbers each day will reflect
the last 24 hours rather than some
variable period based on the flow of
testing so to speak okay we are I guess
getting closer we've got a few more
reporters who are now in the room that's
a good sign that we are soon going to be
getting started let me say thank you to
Alicia Trimble Alicia Trimble is new
member number ten today at join
pakman.com very much appreciate that
thanks Alicia thank you for your support
okay other super chats that are coming
in Robert Archer says I love how fake
Alex Jones spends his money on you
trying to stir negativity keep being
awesome and enjoy that sweet fake Alex
Jones money I will I will do that
porthole says when will Trump try and
shift the blame to Democrats for the
tens of thousands of Corona deaths like
for example the Democrats fake
impeachment
hoax caused early Korona deaths I don't
think it'll be that brazen but I
wouldn't be surprised to see some
version of that for sure
blind man says what says what do you
think of means-testing in the stimulus
do you mean that it that the the 1,200
bucks phases out after 75 K and
completely goes away after 100 K I mean
I think it does make sense I don't know
you know people with successful
businesses or who have jobs that pay a
lot more money and are not you know gig
economy jobs or tipped jobs or whatever
they probably don't need the money
I think that that it's reasonable if
that's what you mean
if you mean something else then
certainly let me know martin Duplessis
says oh what does martin say appreciate
your rigor I like that word rigor and
incisive analysis David you are a beacon
of light in these dark days Thank You
Martin beautiful message today after the
chels
says David thoughts on the House
Resolution blaming China for the
coronavirus haven't looked at it yet
I'll check it out cloud Claudia Cornejo
sends a sort of thumbs up animated image
I appreciate that
let me say thanks to Tigger for the
twitch Prime subscription Diego Maremma
has also subscribed with Prime and about
8:00 to 4:00 has subscribed and says how
can we afford all these new memberships
incredible question completely agree I
don't know how we can do it Frank Witter
says thank you so much David for your
clarity and logic what do you foresee
will be the lasting impact on public
education and universities after now
scrambling to convert traditional
classrooms to online I my prediction is
we are going to see lasting impact in
education telework travel I think I
think that this is this is going to be
one of those moments that we all
remember essentially forever in our
lives as the before and after points
unless you're just partying in Florida
and not even paying attention to what's
going on then you'll either die or not
even notice anything went on let me say
thanks to
I'll Nettleton ell nettleton is new
member number 11 today at join
pakman.com thank you so much Alli I so
appreciate your support and everybody's
support who has signed up as that you
know but we yesterday we were we were
talking have we seen a lot of membership
cancellations due to co vid 19 and we
have and listen I get it right like
you've got to get food you've got to pay
rent you've got to take care of your
kids etc covering you know paying for
independent media shows is very low on a
lot of people's lists and it is it is
one of those things where anybody who
can afford it I very much appreciate but
I get that people are tightening their
belts this is why we have this goal of
25 website members whenever we stream
okay let's see here Jason Ealing says
are you ever gonna do a studio tour yeah
I was gonna film one over the weekend I
got busy with streams and a bunch of
other stuff but I will do a home studio
tour at some point
eg says I only watch the press
conferences through your show subbed on
Twitch a few weeks ago love everything
you do keep it up thank you awesome
gaming says if Trump ends the lockdown
for the virus well they're like a
million to 10 million case by April and
May I don't know what the case number
will be by May if Trump says let it rip
but it's scary it's gonna be a very it's
gonna be a scary number let me put it
that way
Specter Corp says go Ribe maith agat
from Ireland David okay Ben's it Laos
has staggered Peaks across states good
thing or bad depends on which model and
which epidemiologist you you listen to
that's the reality
Jean D says rest in peace USA 1776 to
2016 that's an ominous message
Austin Clark says the only face mask we
need is duct tape on Trump Danny
Thompson says Minnesota governor Tim
waltz always starts on time and he's
doing an incredible job for us
Trump does not start on time that's for
sure
Savini says your URL on YouTube is not
correct it
is a wo no let me let me see if I can
fix that that's a real problem
that's probably hurting the number of
signups that are happening if I miss can
you imagine if I misspelled my own URL
that's horrible let me see here I'm
gonna get that taken care of right away
here it is edit and oh you know what
you're absolutely right you need all
three W's in www got it all set
appreciate that thank you very much I
thank you for correcting that that would
that is ugly that is very very ugly okay
we should just be we are now 32 minutes
late on the start of this press
conference so like I guess it should be
starting soon that's what that's what we
would imagine Gibble's bits has heard
rumors of a general strike what are your
thoughts yeah we dealt with that
yesterday I mean you know there's
there's rumors of so many things I don't
know how how worthwhile it is to explore
unless it becomes more of a reality
unknown prodigy says winning the pact
chess trophy is my dream lol yes
remember tonight 8:00 p.m. 8:00 8:00 or
8:30 no 8:00 8:00 p.m. Eastern David
Pakman show chess tournament okay I will
surely lose the 2019 title because in
2019 it was one game I beat producer Pat
we today are going to have hopefully
more than 50 or 100 people playing I
hope I'm surprised by how many people
play everybody is invited okay
join Pakman I'm sorry Lee chess org the
force of habit there Lee chess org is
where we will do the tournament tonight
starting at 8:00 p.m. make an account
it's free it's gonna be a three plus two
time control three plus two all right
no no buy-in it's free this is free 'man
min ji says ignoring all political
ideological differences I feel like it
would be really fun to get wasted with
Larry Kudlow yet Larry Kudlow seems
frequently to be drunk rich harris says
how many people does the david pakman
show employ and will the David Pakman
show benefit from the stimulus package
well I think the only thing that would
be available to us would be loans and
I'm hoping that we don't have to take
out any loans we have a for employees
for employees Dark Queen says I just
went food shopping and have been
suffering the worst panic attack of my
life I am crying and I really hate Trump
right now yeah food shopping has become
very stressful for a lot of people sadly
it's horrible that that's that's what's
going on let's see here the bond says in
my opinion evangelical pressure because
of Easter is one of the biggest money
earning days very sad
I mean if that's a factor that's
absolutely horrible
okay the super chat just scrolled Donna
William says do people on Social
Security receive anything as far as I
know yes the way that the stimulus
package is written Jackie Tupper says
CPAP equipment can be adjusted to make
them into ventilators I saw an article
about that today thanks to Antonio
Magallanes magallanes for subscribing on
YouTube Shannon Venice's can you shout
out my hard-working are and wife Susanna
yes Susanna thank you
you and all of the other health workers
are doing incredible work and stay safe
and I hope that we get to the other side
of this thing sooner than later
Riz junkie says after things go back to
normal any thoughts on live shows we
adapt something we were I was actually
there was a very very photo I want to
call it
advanced discussion of a tour involving
David Pakman me and a female progressive
commentator prominence the two of us
were going to hit the road and do shows
we were gonna go to Austin we were gonna
go to San Antonio we were going to go to
Indianapolis we were gonna go you know
yeah and all that stuff the Howard Dean
stuff we're not going anywhere right now
that entire thing is on is on hiatus and
I mean I've we all know why right
coronavirus but I hope I hope that the
discussion is resumed sooner than
later and we will do it when it's safe
vibrantly Brantley says I'm an Idaho our
mayor refuses to shut anything down
you're still my favorite David in your
immediate vicinity interesting that you
use the Canadian and British spelling of
favorite despite being in Idaho I wonder
if you are Canadian or from elsewhere
why nosey sends a super chat leave
Barrett says here in Louisiana thanks
for being a voice of reason most of
family is hardcore Trump supporters some
even believe he is sent by God you keep
me sane Thank You Martha guidance says
I'm a nurse and will work until I die I
hope you mean by choice I hope you mean
by choice let me say thank you to Lisa
black ELISA is new member number 12
today at join pakman.com Michael rust is
new member number 13 today at join
pakman.com Michael and Lisa thank you
guys very very much
join pakman.com is the best place for
david pakman show membership s-- let me
say thank you to nolan for the twitch
subscription as well as element 10 is
element 10 one of the elements of
medical I don't I'm not sure about that
Sabrina asks what happened to david
pakman show live show in boston
coronavirus yeah just happened i just
addressed that inconsolable says i
disagree with your take lots of people
who make over a hundred over a hundred
thousand last year are now unemployed
those who are still making a hundred
thousand would spend the 1200 locally no
reason not to provide the money to all
if stimulating local economy is the goal
so fine i mean maybe maybe then the
cutoff is higher but at a certain point
you know if you made a million dollars
last year i don't think you should get
1200 bucks i just don't know at the same
time the number of people who made that
or relatively few I you know I've seen
different arguments on both sides of
that Erin Washington says if you think
coronavirus is bad and it is bad climate
change should terrify you and it does to
many people
Lance Smith says it has been a very
rough three to four weeks working at
Costco I can imagine
so very risky for employees and members
as thousands run through daily grocery
stores Costco medical facilities any
elements of medical are these are
frontline people at this point in time
let's see here what else a rolous says
what do you think of the Republican
amendment to cap unemployment to be
wages and not potentially more I am okay
with making more money to stay home cap
unemployment to be wages and not
potentially more I'm okay with making
more money to stay home yeah that's you
know that I don't yet know how to
comment on that because there is the
question of whether the so there's gonna
be federal government is going to be
supplementing unemployment insurance and
state unemployment insurance and there's
a question of whether the $600 a week
supplement will be for everybody even if
it puts you above the wage you would
normally make or not I'm not hugely
worried about this that we're talking
about stimulus directly to people here
and I think either way if we're talking
about a few hundred bucks one way or the
other
this is money people are going to need
and I'm not hugely worried about it
right and it's temporary remember Randy
right says what do you think the actual
case numbers are right now in the US so
as we at one point there was the idea
that the case numbers may be as high as
oh let me see here that the case numbers
could be anywhere from 10 to 50 times
greater than the official number as we
do more testing the multiple probably is
going to be reduced so it could be
anywhere from you know five to ten five
to fifty I don't I don't really know I I
would be shocked if we had fewer than
640,000 cases the official number right
now is 64 K I think then real number is
probably at least 640 K and probably not
more than I don't even know not more
than 1.5 million I mean IIIi R it's so
hard to know because we don't know to
what degree we are under testing okay
let me say thanks to a few other people
grungy dan and Titanic as Gardens have
cheered over on Twitch if you're joining
on YouTube remember to hit that like
button as well as that subscribe button
both are very very useful to us I want
to say thanks to Andrew whets who is new
member number 14 today at join
pakman.com Jeffrey steward is new member
number 15 today at join pakman.com
thanks very much I appreciate it Bob -
25-ish says if Trump reverses course and
hundreds of thousands died he loses the
20/20 election he can't see the approval
boost was based on his action not in
action that maybe that's an interesting
perspective I have a hard time imagining
how if the death toll really explodes
people still think Trump did a good job
I know it's happening now but I don't I
don't see how that could happen - it's
full - its full conclusion
Daniel Ribeiro says what do you think of
bolsa Narrows response - Cova - get back
to work
irresponsible dangerous and disgusting
is how I would characterize it
Jared Simard says with this pandemic how
should we stay motivated it I don't
think there's any one motivating thing
to say to everybody it really depends on
your situation I think as a general
principle what we have to remember is if
we all act responsibly there will be
another side to this we can minimize
death we can minimize cases it's going
to be tragic it's going to be horrible
but let's all work together and when we
get to the other side hopefully we will
be stronger and more prepared for the
next one for the next one the next time
with our current president I don't know
that that's the case sadly more activity
in the room now so it looks like we are
finally getting a little bit closer to
the start of this thing although we are
now 42 minutes late let me see if they
did reschedule it officially it was
scheduled for 5:00 p.m. still scheduled
for 5:00 p.m. so who the hell knows at
this point what's going on but hopefully
soon Specter Corp says that was thank
you an Irish David you're a tonic
I hope tonic is good it's me John B says
switch to you - because I can't Fig
about picture-in-picture on twitch
mobile this is not an alias says thank
you for doing these streams and keeping
me sane while trump word vomits that's a
good description of what we are seeing
daily let's see here Alexis says what do
you think governor Baker in
Massachusetts response will be if Trump
sticks to his open for business orders
my my guess is Charlie Baker is probably
going to extend Massachusetts just
extended no school until I believe it's
May first
so well what's going on here this is
weird it's a view of some other
you
purposes for now that was really weird
the White House stream is still dead
but PBS newshour is showing something
else is it conceivable that this got
cancelled let's look at the stream from
the Department of State real quick oh
they're just repeating the White House
stuff how weird was that shifting to
another room and then playing music
really really weird I hope that that's
not a bad sign
Wow very odd we've not experienced that
before let me say thank you to Mujib
Hafiz who is new member number 16 today
appreciate that very much 16 signups
today at join pakman.com ok HS dte says
how should BS respond when asked why
medicare for all didn't stop kovat in
italy i mean let's say i think it's a
fraud question there are countries in
italy doing well with nationalized
health care systems and countries in
italy not doing well countries in europe
rather not doing well I think it's a
fraught question in general I just don't
think that that's the right way to be
thinking about this at all Gregory Webb
sends a super chap mr. catfish jr. says
when will they gust push out a TV
monitor with Trump face and he in his
clean room safe ROM I think I get the
picture yeah when is Trump just not
going to even go to the room at all this
is really weird like what what is going
on here
we're now 45 minutes late and PBS has
switched to another room let's see if
there's still audio
so weird
okay there's someone walking around very
very strange very very strange okay
Daniel Michael Sierra says more
important than just liking and
subscribing the show feed is hitting the
bell with YouTube notifications allowed
phone setting can be set to never
actually alert you thanks for your hard
work
beautiful Daniel we beautifully said so
here's the full list of homework for
people watching on YouTube like the
stream subscribe to the channel hit the
bell icon so that you will be notified
and make sure that your phone is not
blocking notifications from YouTube do
all of that stuff right now oh I'm being
told that there's a trump tweet from
four minutes ago about the stream let's
see here
I hear that fake news CNN just reported
I am isolated in the White House
wondering out loud when will life return
to normal
does anybody really believe that there
was no leak they made it up they are
corrupt and fake news I have been packed
all day with meetings I have no time for
stupidity we're working around the clock
to keep America safe okay well then come
and do the stream I could come and do
the briefing we're trying to figure out
where he is he's now 47 minutes late
Jays disguise weaponized ignorance it's
crazy all right Scott Sly Fox says why
wasn't SARS or MERS or before/after
event in world history as you predict
kovat 19 will be it didn't cause the
total and complete shutdown of dozens
and dozens of countries and period I
mean that that's that's essentially
that's the difference Erik Lamont says
where does two trillion in stimulus come
from come from debt thin air the
government just prints the money my
friends I guess we can't afford it Lisa
Black is now a YouTube member Donna
Williams says I can't watch these
briefings without you David thank you
for all that you do Thank You Donna
magma 2400 says kovat 19 can cause
pulmonary fibrosis which is dangerous
later in life I'll develop idiopathic
pulmonary fibrosis due to a pre-existing
condition
I'll dye it by 55 at best even with a
lung transplant that is horrible and we
are learning about the possible
long-term effects of surviving kovat 19
and you know we still don't know we
still don't know what what the full
scope of that is likely to be vibrantly
Brantley says northern Idaho Canada runs
to us here like syrup raw spaghetti and
says happy we're bailing out industry
that used this line coronavirus can only
survive in cold temperatures
so the Caribbean is a fantastic choice
for your next cruise yeah that industry
is getting a bailout Mike McVeigh nee
says what do you think about having 2018
tax to get the so from what I understand
you have to if you filed your 2019 taxes
that can be used as justification for
qualifying for the stimulus check if you
haven't then I guess you're going to be
allowed to use your 2018 tax filing to
justify the $1,200 check which phases
out up to between 75 K and 99 K an
income it'll phase out okay we have no
idea what's going on now Trump tweeting
just five minutes ago eight minutes ago
and still nothing apparently going on in
terms of the press conference very very
bizarre very strange is it possible that
they are waiting for something to happen
in the Senate what is happening in the
Senate nothing
is this if there's everyone standing
still or is this not a life no there is
movement there some guy just looked
around so nothing's happening in the
Senate Senate yeah it's not really clear
what they're waiting for
it's very very very odd now we're back
in the room John Roberts has left so we
don't know we don't know very strange
who knows what's going on let me say
thank you to Lauren Cruz for signing up
at join pakman.com your new member
number 17 today
David Porter you are new member number
18 today thank you very much I
appreciate that
gregory webb says is destiny going on
joe rogan with you no that is not
happening
Jamal Swift says thanks homie a jammu
oma wale says I hope we stop calling
these people that work in places like
restaurants and grocery stores marginal
when they say they deserve higher wages
I agree with that
clearly they are not marginal they are
essential that's becoming very clear and
should have been clear all along I funny
as hell says it's Rudy new-member
longtime fan love your work
shoutout to your data male t-shirt
what's your favorite beer or drink of
choice if any my favorite beer is I
don't I don't think I have a favorite
beer but beers like allagash white UFO
white other white ales are my go-to as
far as beer goes I think it's been weeks
since I've even had a beer since this
entire thing started it's like I have
beer at home but it never really occurs
to me to just go and like grab a beer
well I mean it's weird I don't know why
I could do it could do it but certainly
no Coronas I never drank Coronas let's
see here tone says wouldn't it make
sense that if 80% of cases are mild and
most of those aren't being tested that
the confirmed amount would be about 25%
of actual cases yes that would suggest
that the real number is four times the
official number that's one that's in the
range of what people are suggesting a
lot of milling of
an activity now in the room so maybe
they're getting ready to start beetle
Greg says the cure for Co vyd is
socialism Keeton Klepper says get
Chile's to go don't hoard toilet paper
you know I haven't been to a Chili's or
an Applebee's in like 15 or 20 years I
used to go to those places like with my
high school friends some of my high
school friends still do go to them but
I've not been to any of those places for
a really really long time
I wonder what's going on at them Wolf
Pack says Trump will be in cell mode oh
yeah that today is going to be like a
historically propagandistic press
conference I would I would predict
Pepa's says I'm a chief at a federal
health center do you mean chief ER chef
or no chief okay in New York City and
the price for thirty thousand and ninety
five masks went from thirty thousand a
dollar each to 1.5 million dollars we
have Steven minuchin and dr. Anthony
foul a dr. deborah birx are here and we
could expect Donald Trump to arrive at
any moment would be my guess I want to
say thanks to pare Hezbollah who is new
member number 19 today at join
pakman.com Thank You pear very much
appreciate that we now have two members
named pear we have paired Kieren from
Sweden and then we have also pear hell's
bowl very exciting I know if you had
asked me a few years ago do you think
you will someday have two members named
pear at the same time I probably would
have said I don't think so probably I
don't think so okay looks like everybody
is now running to get into position we
must be very very close to the start of
this the White House feed is also now
live we'll keep it as a backup in case
the audio level of the PBS feed isn't
good looks like this PBS feed is
actually further ahead one somehow one
way or the other
oh speaking of pear tieran he says Wow a
little Simon and Garfunkel me like David
roe is sending a super chat tour Saul's
rude is a new YouTube member hot caramel
says hi David any chance you would do an
only fans and report topless doubtful
very very doubtful
here's Donald Trump followed by Mike
Pence and I guess some guy from Secret
Service let's see what we've got
thank you very much so nice to be with
you America continues to gain ground in
the war against the virus lie more cases
more than the American people for
answering the call following our
guidelines and making these sacrifices
required to overcome this terrible
threat more aggressively we commit to
doing nothing yeah social distancing so
important social distancing such an
important phrase and we do it right now
the more lives that we can save and the
sooner we can eventually get people back
to work back to school and back to
normal and there are large sections of
our country probably can go back much
sooner than other sections and we're
obviously looking at that also people
are asking is that an alternative I say
absolutely it is an alternative I have
now approved major disaster declarations
for New York California Washington Iowa
Louisiana Texas and Florida that has
great significance as you know and legal
significance we're in a constant
grouping and I can say this we have a
large grouping of people that does
nothing but communicate with the various
officials including we've been spending
a lot of time with New York officials
because that really is by far the
hottest spot they've got a number of
very tough weeks ahead of them the
governor's doing a very good job I spoke
to the governor Governor Cuomo last
night and this morning and he mentioned
that in his remarks that he's using the
that we are using and I think he feels
because he understands negotiation he
thinks we're using
very appropriately the defense
production act and we haven't usually
using it where needed it's a great point
of leverage it's a great negotiating
tool but I've really I will tell you
this tremendous spirit from people and
tremendous spirit with respect to these
companies were really screwed guys and I
don't have to use it very much at all
they want to do it as you know General
Motors is involved Ford's involve three
M's involved others are involved and
they're all working very hard to produce
product different all different products
we had very little product when we came
we built it up and we've we give it away
as fast as we can
dear God to the different states we're
also as you know building numerous
hospitals and medical centers throughout
certain areas in New York it's at the
convention center the Javits Convention
Center we're doing for hospitals and
we're doing throughout the state for
medical centers they're somewhat
different I want you to know that I'm
doing everything in my power to help the
city pull through this challenge I'm
working very hard in New York it's
really by far our biggest problem maybe
it will be maybe it won't be but there's
a lot of good capable people working on
it with us and our teams are working
very well with the state representatives
we're also doing some very large
testings throughout the country I told
you yesterday that in South Korea this
is not a knock in any way because if I
just spoke with president moon we had a
very good conversation about numerous
other things but they've done a very
good job in testing but we now are doing
more testing than anybody by far not per
capita we do more in eight days and they
do in eight weeks meaning within a per
capita we go up on a daily basis
exponentially it's not X no it's really
good by the way while I'm on it I'd also
spoke with Prime Minister Robbie of
Japan last night and I congratulated him
on a wise choice I think it's going to
be a fantastic Olympics 2021
I think it's gonna be a fantastic
Olympics it was the absolute right
decision to delay it for a full year and
now have a full beautiful Olympics it's
going to be very important because it's
probably the first time maybe ever or
certainly in a long time that it was on
a year so we've done an even year yeah
tell me I would have a fantastic success
and now that I've even more time he
didn't need any more time everything
imagine being 73 and not having realized
that all Olympics are on even years
alternating summer in winter a and Prime
Minister are you on a great decision I
think it's going to be a fantastic
Olympics I told them I'll be there I'll
be there as we fight to protect American
lives we're also protecting American
livelihoods Democrats and Republicans in
the Senate are very close to passing an
emergency relief bill for American
workers families and businesses this
legislation in addition to the two bills
I signed this month that includes you
know sick leave and we have all sorts of
things in for the workers for families
but we have a tremendous paid sick leave
provision for workers at no cost at all
to the employers and that's a big thing
no cost to the employers we want to get
everybody back working together this 2.2
trillion dollar legislative package is
bigger than anything huge back I believe
ever passed in Congress perhaps
relatively speaking if you go back look
during the FDR New Deal days there was
something that if you time value it you
could say it was bigger I don't know but
this is certainly in terms of dollars by
far and away the biggest ever ever done
and how many lives will that save again
thing because a lot of this money goes
to jobs jobs jobs and families families
families the Senate bill as you know
includes 350 billion dollars in job
retention loans for small businesses
with loan forgiveness available for
businesses that continue paying their
workers they continue paying their
workers that's what we want we want them
to keep their workers and pay their
workers this while businesses keep
workers in the payroll that allow our
economy to quickly accelerate as soon as
we defeat the virus 300 billion dollars
in direct cash payments will be
available for every American citizen
earning less than ninety nine thousand
dollars per year that would be three
thousand four hundred dollars very
quickly for the typical family of four
nothing like that's ever been done in
our country now probably 250 billion
dollars in expanded unemployment
benefits the average worker who has lost
his or her job will receive 100% of this
salary for up to four full months unlike
normal unemployment benefits independent
country I don't know about you guys but
I'd rather him talk about cases testing
treatment isolation etc instead of just
coming out it's all it's all stocks
business that's all it is now and it's
not that that doesn't matter but it's
almost like he doesn't care about the
death toll the heroic work of our
doctors nurses and hospitals they've
been incredible forty five billion
dollars for disaster relief fund so we
are setting up a fund to forty five
billion dollars for disaster relief
that's more than doubling the amount
available to support my national
emergency and disaster declarations
it's a doubling up twenty seven billion
dollars to build up the strategic
national stockpile with critical
supplies including masks respirators
pharmaceuticals and everything you can
imagine because it was very depleted
like our military was depleted now we
have a brand-new military had a military
like this we have equipment either
coming or it's already come for the most
part it's already come but we have a lot
of things that will soon be coming
planes missiles rockets need a lot of
that for fighting the virus but the
stockpile was very depleted like
everything else this will also include
significant funding for the development
of VAX
scenes on top of the eight billion
dollars we approved several weeks ago
over five hundred billion dollars in
support for the hardest-hit industries
with a ban on corporate stock buybacks
which is something I insisted on and
frankly I tell you the Republicans
wanted that and the Democrats wanted
that we want him to use the money for
the companies and the planes or whatever
they may be helping to get over this
rough patch and I don't think it's gonna
end up being such a rough patch I think
it's gonna when we open especially if we
can open it the sooner the better
it's gonna open up like a rocket ship I
think it's going to go very good
originally certainly go up and you can
have some tough new limits on executive
compensation also they need the money
they're gonna have to sort of just make
things work because we're interested in
the workers the jobs and we're
interested in the companies because
that's really what what fuels the
workers in those great jobs and we also
have sixteen billion dollars in funding
for the purchase of personal protective
equipment you know about that such as
masks and respirators through the
strategic national stockpile I encourage
the house to pass this vital legislation
and send the bill to my desk for
signature without delay I will sign it
immediately we will have a signing and
it'll be a great signing and a great day
for the American worker and if they will
heart American families and frankly for
American companies some of which were
having the best years they've ever had
his last few years and then a little bit
less than a month ago they went into a
position that they haven't seen because
of the hidden enemy the virus the
invisible earlier today I spoke to the
leaders of many of America's amazing
nonprofit organizations I thank them for
their unwavering and unwavering devotion
to American people to American families
to our nation and they have been
fantastic they've been
electing supplies distributing food
supporting health care workers caring
for vulnerable workers and Families I
encourage them to continue to do it but
I'll tell the nonprofit's have been
fantastic they've been great they're
great people actually I know a lot of
them finally I want to provide a brief
update on the critical supplies through
FEMA the federal government is delivered
or is in the process of shipping nine
point four million n95 respirators think
of that nine point four million twenty
million
surgical masks and we have others that
we think are going to be delivered
pretty quickly the whole world you know
it's not just us it's not just the
states the whole world is trying to get
these things so come in competition with
many many countries I believe today you
broke the hundred and fifty mark for the
virus we have a hundred and fifty
countries over a hundred and fifty
countries where you have this virus how
about we're about to happen and nobody
would ever believe a thing like that's
plus so well nobody could have ever seen
something like this coming but now we
know when we know it can happen and
happen again and if it does somebody's
going to be very well prepared because
of what we've learned and how we've done
it's been incredible how we've done
remember there's more tests than anybody
by far and the news and reporters the
media it was likes to bring South Korea
they called me and they told me it's
amazing your testing procedures are
amazing plus we have a test that's a
very high level test and it's a test
that's very accurate high low 3.1
million face shields 2.6 million
surgical gowns 14.6 million gloves and
almost six thousand ventilators which go
to the areas of greatest needs we sent
over the last day four thousand
ventilators to New York and I spoke with
the governor about that he was happy I
spoke with the mayor also about that
Merida Blasio he was very I don't think
everything's great it's hard not to be
happy with the job we're doing oh yeah I
tell you throughout the clip that it's
hard not to be happy with what's going
on those continue to step forward and
demonstrate the extraordinary care
character of our nation including the
people behind me by the way these people
are amazing they are amazing people and
they become I don't know maybe I should
just speak for myself but that maybe
they become friends maybe they don't
like me maybe they don't maybe they do I
don't know all I can tell you is if they
have talented people they work very hard
in Maryland a seven-year-old boy used
his own birthday money to buy meals for
dozens of senior citizens called
dystopian Nevada a college student
recruited 90 of her friends to help
deliver groceries and supplies shouldn't
be necessary the most vulnerable this is
happening all over the country thousands
and thousands of instances I could stand
up here all day and tell you about other
things in Minnesota hundreds of medical
students have volunteered to provide
child care for hospital workers helping
to keep our doctors and nurses on the
front lines fighting to save lives these
inspiring Americans remind us that we
all have a role to play in winning this
great nation one of these stories are
like Jimmy was able to do a bake sale to
raise money for four you know Jane's
cancer treatment and it's like well why
is that even necessary is that inspiring
or is a dystopian jeez are in big
trouble so now we will hear from our
great Secretary of the Treasury he's
been working rather hard I will tell you
Steve Malucci is a fantastic guy and he
loves our country and he's been dealing
with both sides Republicans and
Democrats you sort of lived over in that
beautiful building it's a very beautiful
building yeah to me one of the most
beautiful buildings actually in the
world I know it Steve very well so if we
could have a little update state would
be fantastic as to how we're doing and
what it's looking like thank you thank
you very much mr. president
and first let me say I would like to
thank Mitch McConnell for his leadership
I'd also like to thank Chuck Schumer for
the enormous bipartisan support we had
on this bill and the many senators both
Republicans and Democrats that work
tirelessly over the last five days on
all the task force the president said I
got to live in the LBJ room for the last
five days and we couldn't be
more pleased with the unprecedented
response from the Senate to protect
American workers and American business
in this situation the president has
outlined many of these but let me just
quickly go through them again small
business retention loans this will cover
roughly 50% of the private payroll in
small businesses where we will
immediately make loans that will supply
eight weeks of salaries as long as they
keep workers employed and overhead and
those loans will be forgiven at the end
of the period as long as they keep
workers employed these are SBA loans but
the Treasury will be issuing new
regulations authorizing almost every
single FDIC insured bank to make these I
expect by the end of next week
we will have a very simple process where
these can be made and dispersed in the
same day so this will be a very simple
system to get money into small business
hands for companies that don't qualify
that we have a economic program of tax
incentives to retain workers and as the
president said we have enhanced
unemployment insurance for people don't
fit into these two programs that will be
administered through the states we also
have economic impact payments these will
be within the next three weeks direct
payments into most people's deposit
accounts and for those that don't have
it we will be having the the checks in
the mail
Treasury will have additional
authorities we have five hundred billion
dollars that we can use to work with the
Federal Reserve for emergency programs
that will create up to an additional
four trillion dollars if needed to
support American business and American
workers in an unprecedented way and then
finally the president mentioned a
hundred billion dollars to hospitals and
150 billion dollars to states that have
specific coronavirus expenses as well as
many additional things mr. president I
especially want to thank you and the
vice president
you were constantly available to us we
spoke constantly throughout the day you
gave us guidance and quick decisions on
many issues and again thank everybody
for this great bipartisan work this is
going to be enormous help for the
American workers in the American economy
the president was very determined that
Congress would move swiftly to protect
hardworking Americans in business in
this unprecedented situation thank you
wow that's good day and night that was
there's a lot of work and I got so lean
a vote Steve don't really hand you have
a question yes you think this bill will
keep the economy afloat we have to go
back we have to go back to we take care
of the American worker we're gonna take
care of these companies that fuel this
country and make the country great it's
not their fault it's not their fault
look we think hopefully this war will be
won quicker but we expect that this is a
significant amount of money if needed to
cover the economy and don't forget a lot
of this is going to be to keep companies
that are very strong triple-a rated
companies previously to keep them going
and it's gonna be in the form of loan so
the money's gonna come back
this money's got a lot of this money's
coming back let me ask you about
something you said yesterday you said we
should never be reliant on a foreign
country for the means of our own survive
yeah many countries give up our supply
chains we give up our factories in case
anybody's wondering this is about a
pandemic I know nothing's been mentioned
yet about isolation treatment cases
deaths no none of that's been mentioned
but this is about a pandemic I guess
pendants and we can't let that happen so
we'll be making some changes we have
been making those changes in an
executive order to basically ban
bored of medical equipment I don't
really will need that but I think it's
happening by itself I think a lot of
things are happening well some people we
make the best medical equipment in the
world and you have some people like the
European Union they don't take it
because they have specifications that
don't allow our equipment in because
it's designed in a different way even
though it's a better way it's designed
they're all they're all playing games
against us okay they've been playing
games against us for years and no
president has ever done anything about
it but the European Union you look at
medical equipment we make the best
medical equipment in the world but we
can't sell it because or not
appropriately and yet we take their
medical equipment in our country we're
changing things Steve all this is
changing but they have specifications so
that our equipment designed specifically
so that our equipment can't come into
their countries somehow I don't know
that this is accurate that's happened to
our country and let me tell you some of
the people that took the biggest
advantage of us our allies you know we
talk about allies oh boy they took
advantage of us in many ways but
financially as well as even militarily
when you look at look I got if you look
at NATO the abuse that was given to our
country or NATO where they wouldn't pay
and we were paying for everybody we're
paying now because of me NATO now they
paint a lot now they paid a hundred and
twenty five hundred and thirty five
billion dollars more and then ultimately
Secretary General Stoltenberg oh I think
what you would say is maybe my biggest
fan we got him to pay an additional four
hundred billion dollars billion other
countries and but but you know that and
then there's the trade they make it they
make it almost impossible for us to have
a fair deal they know this day no I'm
just waiting we have all the advantages
by the way it's going to be easy when I
decide to do it but this isn't the right
time to do it but we've been treated
very very on
by the European Union mr. mr. president
for Republican sinners have indicated
and two extra $600 for unemployment
insurance may encourage workers to leave
their jobs even though you can only
collect unemployment if you're fired
I'm curious what you think of that
concern well I know the issue very well
we talked about it just a little while
ago
I'll let Steve over there like you maybe
discussed it sure no the president I
spoke to several of the Senators today
but let me just explain the issue which
is we wanted to have enhanced
unemployment insurance
most of these state systems have
technology that's 30 years old or older
so if we had the ability to customize
this with much more specifics we would
have this was the only way we could
assure that the states could get money
out quickly in a fair way so we used six
hundred dollars across the board and I
don't think it'll create incentives most
Americans what they want they want to
keep their jobs and I said for 50% of
these these businesses they will have
the businesses keep those jobs so this
was in our number one issue was how do
we make sure that American workers who
needed to keep getting paid this is no
fault of their own that businesses have
been shut down the president and
vice-president wanted to make sure those
hardworking Americans got money and this
was the most efficient way of doing it
she spoke with are they in agreement now
I'm not gonna comment on the specifics
of where they are but I would say you
know our expectation is this bill passes
tonight and gets to the house tomorrow
and they pass it we need to get this
money into the American economy and
American workers that's the importance
of this good thing when you think about
that people would get actually more
money but we don't want to give a
disincentive but they have been talking
about that it's a good question actually
yes
thank you the family of another subject
the family of retired FBI agent Robert
Levinson says that US officials have
concluded that he's died in Iranian
custody were you aware it back and yeah
you know I've been very much involved in
that and he was a great gentleman and a
great family it's just I mean I have to
say this and they've been making the
statement to the family I believe but
it's not looking good he wasn't well
four years anyway in Iraq it's not
looking promising
we've gotten so many people back we've
got two people back this week but Robert
Levinson who was outstanding he was he's
been sick for a long time and in it some
rough problems prior to his detainment
to a capture and we feel terribly for
the family but no I don't accept that
he's dead I don't accept it I mean I'm
telling you it's not it's not looking
great but I won't accept that he's dead
he wanted to haven't told us that he's
dead but a lot of people are thinking
that that is the case
he's does not accept still barely
another tweeted earlier linking the
closing of the country to your election
success in in November is this Easter
timeline based on your political
interest wouldn't I
you said that the media wants the
country remain close to her I think that
ya know the media would like to see me
do poorly in the election I think I
think what is that that's just so you
understand are you ready I think there
are certain people that would like it
not to open so quickly I think there are
certain people that would like it to do
financially poorly because they think
that would be very good as far as
defeating me at the polls mock-ups ahead
I don't know if that's so but I do think
it's so that a lot of that there are
people in your profession that would
like that to happen I think it's very
clear I think it's very clear that there
are people in your profession that write
fake news you do she does there are
people in your profession that write
fake news they would love to see me for
whatever reason tactic because we've
done one hell of a job nobody's done the
job that we've done and it's lucky that
you have this group here right now for
this problem I would say our expectation
is within three weeks we will have
direct payments out where we have
depository information nasty and we're
looking to get a lot more information
and we have procedures to do that so
three weeks for that
that's the lunatics seat right like
that's where the oen people sit that's
where Sean Spicer once asked the
question and Trump pretended not to
recognize him and now this guy from
Christian Broadcasting what is this a
swarm that at least
with the g20 leaders and I want to know
if you're gonna lead an effort to craft
a wolf-like ban on wild animal market so
as to prevent another pandemic given
them a little bit 19 is a zoonotic that
was transferred to humans in trade or
exotic cattle yeah I don't know that
that subjects going to come up there is
a lot of talk that that's how this all
happened came out of China and they say
that's how it happened in China so it's
something maybe we'll be talked about
but it's not the top of my list and also
and dr. Hershey Schaaf who's the head of
Harvard's Global Health Institute says
that the key to getting this economy
open as soon as possible
is to test everyone who needs testing so
we can quarantine all infected
individuals and allow everyone else to
go back to work immediately would you
subscribe to strategy no but we have
tested more than anybody actually I saw
if not how many deaths are acceptable
yeah how many none okay how many deaths
are acceptable to me and none too late
okay none if that's your question look I
saw him I saw his statement we have
tested by far more than anybody not for
testing more than anybody right now
I'm confident close and our tests are
the best test they're the most accurate
tests but if you're saying we're going
to test three hundred and fifty million
people I watched his statement I
disagree with it we can go to certain
states I could name him now but I'm not
gonna do that but we can go to certain
states right now there virtually no
problem we're a very small problem we
don't have to test the entire state in
the natal West or wherever they may be
we'd have to test the entire state I
think it's ridiculous we don't have to
do it a lot of those states could go
back right now and they probably will
because at some point in the
not-too-distant future certain states
are gonna come off the rolls maybe New
York Kent and maybe California can't
maybe the state of Washington can't
although if you look at them their
biggest problem was in one nursing home
yeah go ahead but the states are
and so I mean somebody if you test one
state and then the person moves over to
the other state well then you're gonna
just look at that but if you take a look
at the states and look at in many states
that I'm talking about they don't have a
problem we have some big problems but
it's confined to certain areas high
density areas so why would we test the
entire nation 350 people with that being
said I'm gonna say it again
we tested far more than anybody else not
per capita we are we have the ability to
test
I mean we've come a long way from an
obsolete broken system that I inherited
we have now tested with the best test
far more than anybody else who want to
see anybody else I'm talking about other
countries no country is even close they
came out with a statistic I guess
yesterday that I heard from dr. Burks
where it's four eight eight days here
more than eight weeks in South Korea and
South Korea done a good job but we did
in eight days more than South Korea did
in eight we have way more people not
happening and we're getting I said
before exponentially better that's not
true every day is going up substantially
we have an incredible apparatus built
now but no I never the size of his
apparatus where it's not I don't think
he knows the definition of exponential
it's ridiculous yes please because they
you aim
g20 countries - for more resources for a
coordinated stimulus package ban on
tariffs wave on sanctions to try to
prevent what they call and apocalyptic
pandemic would you consider those
measures and with respect to work on
tariffs and also related also to waive
tariffs and also our strong orders and
would you consider to join this global
effort so before I came here we weren't
into borders we had a country people
could come in we had a whole different
deal very light now we're up to almost a
hundred and sixty four miles think of
that one hundred and sixty four miles of
wall big beautiful wall and in those
areas it's very very tough to come in
we've been very tough on the borders I
mean where we have the wall built where
nobody's getting through now they're
going around nobody but that's a long
trip if they're going around that's the
way they get through but no I'm very
strong on borders and I don't want
people coming in here I what I want is
if they're gonna come and have to come
in Legally they have to come in through
a merit and now we're not having the
people that you're talking about come
into our country all right sir question
for you then for a few let me both
Republican and Democrats packages of the
stimulus included twenty five million
dollars worth of funding for the Kennedy
performance arts center here in
Washington DC
shouldn't that money be going to masks
respirators know what I approve that and
I knew it was thirty five million and we
actually took off ten but I'm a fan of
that although I haven't spent time there
because I'm far too busy I'd love to go
there evenings but I'm too busy doing
things because that's more important for
me than going there but the Kennedy
Center has suffered greatly because
nobody can go there it's essentially
closed and they do need some funding and
I said look that was a Democrat request
that was not my request but you got to
give him something it's something that
they wanted you know it works that way
where the Democrats have treated us
fairly
I really believe that we've had a very
good back-and-forth and I say that with
respect to Chuck Schumer I spoke to him
a number of times but you know they had
requests also so that was a request or
35 yes you know and it came down to 25
we got it down to 25 we agreed I said
that's a lousy two soundbite that's not
a good sound bite but that's the way
life works with that being said the
Kennedy Center they do a beautiful job
an incredible job David Rubenstein does
a fantastic job he's very much involved
and he puts up a lot of money and he
does things that a lot of people
wouldn't be able to do or do but they've
been essentially closed they have
tremendous deficits that are built up I
mean this thing has been devastating to
it so I didn't have a big problem with
it but this was a request from the
Democrats because of the fact that they
have a facility that's essentially
closed down yeah another question serve
I wanted to go there tonight to look at
Romeo and Juliet I'd love to see Romeo
and Juliet tonight you know what
happened sorry
250 people or 50 people whatever it
might be down to good yeah and then
earlier today Senator Marco Rubio told
RCP that quote the World Health
Organization showed favoritism to China
on flow and then representative Michael
McCall the ranking member on the the
House Foreign Relations Committee he
questioned the integrity of the World
Health Organization's director saying
quote that there were several red flags
in his past with respect to his
relationship with China do you agree do
you think the World Health Organization
showed favoritism and then once all the
dust settles do you think that the
United States should restore its
relationship with the World Health
Organization of certainly a lot of talk
that has been very unfair I think that a
lot of people feel that it's been very
unfair it's been very very much sided
with China and a lot of people are not
happy about it at the same time doctor
foul chair myself and other people there
are people on there that we like and we
know a lot of I think your friends are a
lot of good people a lot of good
professionals I don't know be
interesting to hear if you'd like to
talk about the world whf but the fact is
that I have heard for years that that is
very much biased toward China so
I don't know you already get us
political message no I don't want you to
do that but I will so Ted Rose is really
an outstanding person I've known him
from the time that he was the Minister
of Health of Ethiopia I mean obviously
over the years anyone who says that the
w-h-o has not had problems has not been
watching the w-h-o but I think under his
leadership they've done very well he has
been all over this I was on the phone
with him a few hours ago leading at WH o
call no I'm not sure I'm not talking
about China you asked me about Ted Rose
will help organization phrasing China
for transparency and leadership on their
response the pandemic you know I I can't
comment on that because I mean that I
don't have any viewpoint into it I mean
I don't I don't even know what your
question is let me just tell you I have
heard that for years I spoke to him
yesterday seems fine to me I don't know
but we're the ones that gave the great
response and we're the ones that kept
China out of here and if I didn't do it
you'd have thousands and thousands of
people died would have died that are now
living and happy if I didn't do that
early call on China and nobody wanted
that to happen everybody thought it was
a just unnecessary to do it and if we
didn't out you just drop the banhammer
but would have died more than what's
happened so that's it right maybe one
more Steve gun when you have this g20
meeting tomorrow what sort of
coordinated response are you expect
20 Nations total including us and
there'll be it'll be a conference call
tomorrow morning sometime I look forward
to people I know I like I think in every
instance I like every one of them cute
but it'll be an interesting call you'll
be the first to know next week when the
15-day period is what what should we
expect that are you gonna extend it for
another I'll be speaking I'll be
speaking with Tommy I'll be speaking
with Debra be speaking with some of the
people that they like and respect and
Mary is probably gonna bring along with
them we'll be speaking to vice president
Mike Pence and Steve and we'll be
speaking to everybody I'm not gonna do
anything rash or hastily I don't do that
but the country wants to get back to
work our country was built to get back
to work we don't have the country where
they say hey let's close it down for two
years we can't do that it's not our
country so we're gonna be talking and it
could be will do sections of our country
there's big sections of our country that
are very you know little affected by
what's taking place then there are other
sections that are very heavily affected
so there's a big difference but no I
would say by Easter we'll have a
recommendation and maybe before Easter
and at the end of the fifteenth day or
even during the fifteenth day I think
we'll have some kind of a recommendation
but our country wants to get back to
work Steve I have had so many people and
they want to practice social distancing
and they want to practice no handshaking
no handshaking they're not going to walk
around hugging and kissing each other in
the office when they come back even
though they may feel like it they're
gonna do they're gonna wash their hands
more than they've ever done they're
gonna do all the things you're supposed
to do but Steve you know what it's it's
time they want people want to get back
to work it's been seven I guess you know
I get it from both sides and also doing
nothing and maybe it's a combination of
both Tony said before combination of
both is sometimes very good but there
are areas that possibly probably they
won't qualify there are other areas that
qualify almost now so we're gonna have
to see what happens but it'll be an
interesting period of time
I'd like to get our country back I have
tremendous numbers of people wanting to
go back you have store owners with a
store or sitting there they don't know
what's happened they got to get back
you have businesses that are going to be
closed the longer we stay out the longer
we do it we want to go quickly to longer
we stay out the harder it is to bring
this incredible we're having the most
successful years that we've ever had in
the history of our country you saw what
happened yesterday with the stocks and
today they're up I'm telling you if
Steve gets the deal done the incredible
incentive to its going to take care of
people it's gonna take care of our
workers gonna take care of companies
that employ all these workers small and
big by the way I would say we spend more
time on the small company Steve that we
get in the big companies you know people
ask about that we spend more time
thinking about the small businesses than
the big and that's but yes you know that
really fuels our country we want to get
back and the people want to get back we
want to get our country going again and
we'll be able to do that so vice
president's going to stay with you and
gonna take a few more questions
specifically and I will see you tomorrow
thank you very much all right guys
that's gonna do it for me as well I do
have to get ready for the David Pakman
show chess tournament at 8:00 p.m. 90
minutes from now I hope you will play so
come participate I'll be streaming again
in 90 minutes and we'll have the